في زمن الازمات الاقتصاديه لن تكون في
مامن حتى وان كنت خلف مكتبك في العمل اكثر
من حرفيا يتقن مهنته اليدويه كانت جار او
حلاق او حتى عامل بناء
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نتحدث بالضروره عن دول الغرب حيث
موجات الاقالات في شركات التكنولوجيا
مثل الاردن حيث للمهن الحرفيه ميزاته لا
تتوافر في غيرها مثل حريات ساعات العمل
وعدم احتياجها الى راس مال كبير وملاءمتها
لذوي الدراسه المحدوده
[موسيقى]
والاهم من ذلك العوائد السريعه والمزيه
فبحسب الارقام يتراوح متوسط الاجور في
مهنه السباكه ما بين 620 دينارا شهريا
وتصل الى 920 دينارا شهريا مقارنه بخريجه
هندسه يتقاضى 300 الى 400 دينار شهريا
وفي امريكا والدول المتقدمه نجد نوعا
مميزا من الرعايه لهذه المهن حيث اصبحت
السباكه في المرتبه الثانيه ضمن افضل مهن
المقاولات هناك وفي المرتبه الخامسه كافضل
مهنه دون تعليم اما من ناحيه الدخل فهي في
المرتبه التاسعه كافضل لوظيفه تضر دخلا
دون درجه علميه جامعيه
في ما يصلوا اجر السباك من ساعات العمل
الاضافيه فقط الى 200 الف دولار سنويا
اضافه الى راتبه الثابت الذي يصل الى 90
الف دولار سنويا
[موسيقى]